think like what's really interesting in
that regard is I think like philosophy
as a kind of like a tool set right and
you can apply those tools to really any
field and I think most of the time you
know those barriers between different
disciplines are really just artificially
construed and it really helps and if
less you really have to see that because
it's just clear thinking right clear
thinking can be applied to any different
problem and it this is how you reach
good conclusions it's not like you know
there are different sub methods and
different fields but I think it's just
about trying to figure out how to reach
how to get down to the bottom of the
truth and every field really by using
good tools by using logic and reason and
free speech and argument and I think
that is what philosophy teaches you
really well and well first I think all
of those different subfields that I was
interested in like another one and there
was the kind of like part of my
involvement and also like more of the
political sphere with Flushing public
policy and then also working in and
politics for a little bit was and this
aspect of creating new alternatives to
the current system and creating better
governance mechanisms and and you know
that because I think that getting that
right makes it much more likely that we
get everything else right but to me
those there's interest in longevity this
interests in AI and in any kind of
alternative governance and kind of like
projects like seasteading or or rather
of those projects those but they always
kind of seemed to me like unrelated
until I moved to the babe and and then
suddenly I had was like me of like wait
a moment people actually care about all
of those things and it was really it was
really to me I mean the Bears often
called a bubble right because people you
know like live in those like living the
the silos of this kind of like you know
like conflict more futurists were being
focused kind of excitable
that is enabled by technology but for me
it was really not an anchor chamber and
it still isn't because I was not ever in
that kind of community before so coming
here and suddenly realizing because I
did effective altruism as well at
university but more in the sense that
back then it was still a little bit more
current focus like trying to do good
right now and now that it has become a
little bit more futurist with AI safety
it kind of seems like in the pages it
pulls all those strings together right
you have this alternative society
building movement of like seasteading on
of the blockchain ecosystem you have
people working on AI and AI safety you
have people that are really concerned
about getting about really making sure
that that we create wellbeing for future
generations as well yeah and suddenly
all of the under longevity - right it's
it's a really big big project here and
suddenly all of those threats were
pulled together and I was I was
flabbergasted that people care about
really the same things and and many of
them